en 2020 apple a renouvelé une partie des
ipad l'ipad pro le plus haut de gamme a
été bien évidemment renouveler continue
d'aller plus loin
là c'est l'excellent 5 on peut trouver
aujourd'hui chez apple on à l'ipad r qui
a pris un vrai coup de jeune qui était
très bien qu'on allait parler d'autres
jours avec l'arrivée notamment du magic
qui bordent disponible sur l'ipad pro
mais également sur l'ipad r très très
bel accessoire également le magic qui
bordent vous en ai déjà également pas
dans une vidéo précédente
et puis là on à l'ipad de septième
génération qui a été renouvelé avec un
ipad de huitième génération
vous le mettez dans le mille avec un
smart qui bordent qui vient se connecter
on peut également l'utiliser avec
l'apple pencil de première génération
alors la question qu'on va se poser
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que cet ipad 8
s'était pas de huitième génération et au
final un vrai bon plan et bien écoutez
je vais tout vous dire le temps pour moi
de le déverrouiller voilà avec touch
heidi parce qu ici on a taillé d'y aller
on est vraiment sur un design bout que
je me serais tombé un petit peu un petit
peu à l'ancienne mais qui malgré tout
reste très efficace
on est à moins de 400 euros on ne peut
pas tout avoir à ce prix là quels sont
les concessions qu'apple a fait est ce
qu'il est intéressant pour vous quels
sont les points positifs quels sont les
points négatifs qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
est-ce qu'il faut acheter l'ipad de
vittel génération alors tout y est
directement allé sur l'ipad r l'ipad 2
8e génération est un ipad d'entrée de
gamme je vous le mets à côté là de
l'ipad r de cette année pour vous voyez
vraiment la différence c'est vraiment
important de s'en rend compte
on voit qu'on a débord qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus fin que sur l'ipad de
huitième génération du fait notamment
que touch heidi était placé sur un
bouton en haut sur le dessus et non pas
ici ça lui permet d'avoir un écran plus
grand plus dégagée mais si ce n'est pas
le même prix puisque son ipad 2 8l
génération de base
eh bien on est à 389 euros et sur l'ipad
r on est à 669 euros on est dans un
design qu'on a déjà vu et revu chez
apple avec touch elle dit si tu reste
malgré tout toujours très efficace pour
venir déverrouiller assez facilement
votre caméra facetime qui est caché ici
à l'avant ce qui reste conserver qui est
intéressant ici c'est la prise jack
c'est le seul ipad de 2020 qui conserve
sa prise jack après c'est intrigant
classique un votre bouton ici bouton de
volume votre porte et nippon vient la
recharger et ici des smart connector
pour venir brancher votre clavier à
l'arrière une petite caméra de 8
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.4
on a un écran retina de 10
de pouce c'est une dalle ip s2000 160
par 1620 pixels à 264 pixels par pouce
on a ici une luminosité maximale de 500
litres et surtout il est compatible avec
l'apple pencil de première génération on
ne vient pas le recharger en induction
il pas du tout et nantes et non lui par
contre pour se recharger
et bien vous allez utiliser votre
connecteurs lightning ça ça reste
également un peu aux coûts en termes de
technologie aujourd'hui chez apple mais
une fois de plus on reste dans l'entrée
de gamme soyons très clairs tout de
suite comme on est sur un ipad d'entrée
de gamme
on ne va pas tout faire on ne pourra pas
tout faire cet ipad est destiné pour de
la productivité familiale pour la
productivité chez vous à la maison donc
vous allez pouvoir faire de la prise de
notes ce pouvoir faire quelques croquis
si vous souhaitez mais vous n'irez pas
aussi loin que si vous avez un apple
pencil de deuxième génération un ipad r
ou encore un ipad pro donc pour regarder
des films des séries du contenu
multimédia ça ira très bien pour jouer à
vos jeux préférés et ça fera également
la faire oui là je vous ai montré un jeu
auquel jouent elliott donc c'est pas
forcément le jeu auquel vous vous allez
jouer mais bon bout de temps en temps
une petite partie de monster truck ça
marche très très bien
la bonne nouvelle ici c'est que vous
avez la puce à 12
bionic c'est une plus qu'il ya deux ans
on est sur un ipad d'entrée de gamme on
ne va pas avoir ici la puce à 14
bionique mais la a12 bionique marche
prévient vous permettra de faire tourner
tous les jeux qui vous intéressent de
l'app store ça apportera également en
termes de fluidité en terme d'expérience
puisque son expérience officiels
derrière
eh bien vous avez ipad aurès 14 qui
tournera très bien sans aucun problème
le seul bémol que je vais avoir c'est
sur la configuration de base vous avez
soit 32 gigas de stockage soit 128 le
32e pour moi non c'est beaucoup trop
fait beaucoup trop petit effectivement
le prix sera beaucoup plus intéressant
que si vous allez sur la version 128 go
de stockage
je donne les tarifs dans quelques
instants par contre dès que vous allez
installer pas mal d'applications vous
allez commencer à voir des jeux ou
pourquoi pas quelques films téléchargés
dedans eh bien vous risquez rapidement
de manquer de place vous allez devoir
supprimer du contenu pourront
télécharger d'autres et arrive à un
moment ça nous fera réellement râler
donc même si vous avez payé votre ipad
plus cher partait vraiment sur la
version 128 giga de stockage ça aurait
été bien qu'apple nous prévoit une
config de base en 64 giga de stockage
aurait pu la recommander mais la 32 pour
moi c'est beaucoup trop faible il ya un
autre point que je devenir regretter ici
c'est que bien qu'apple nous emm idée
haut parleurs stéréo et bien ils sont
l'objet du même côté ici et ici
ce qui fait que vous n'avez pas du tout
une expérience stéréoscopique même si
vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo ça
c'est vraiment dommage parce que se
rendaient l'expérience beaucoup plus
loin du point de vue multimédia pourquoi
tout nous avons mis du même côté alors
sortez tellement bien de pouvoir avoir
un haut parleur qui se situe de l'autre
côté pour avoir une réelle expérience
stéréoscopique on pourra se consoler en
disant qu'effectivement eh bien on a une
prise jack
on voit qu'on reste également dans
l'entrée de gamme pour la technologie
bluetooth parce qu'ici on les surnomme
bluetooth 4 points 2 on ne parlera pas
ici bien évidemment pas du tout de
bluetooth 5.0 et encore moins d'un peu
tout seul point mais l'intérêt réel de
cette tablette vient de son os avec ipad
ios 14
vous avez exactement le même os vous
avez retrouvé dans l'ipad pro ou dans
l'ipad r il est extrêmement rien et très
complet en terme d'utilisation donc pour
tous ceux qui veulent arriver chez apple
avec un ipad et bien avec pas de
huitième génération peut faire la faire
oui et non parce que ça dépend de vos
usagers de ce que vous voulez en faire
il ya deux choses essentielles ici à
voir c'est effectivement le prix si on
s'intéresse à l'aipac de huitième
génération s'y colle va pas forcément
mettre quasiment 700 euros dans un ipad
donc on regarde ce style pas de là où
l'on a c'est pas mal j'ai envie d'être
sur ipadou sg-1 ac j'ai un iphone je
veux dans l'écosystème c'est vraiment
cette idée là alors qu'est ce qu'on va
venir faire avec cet ipad en gare faire
de la prise de notes on peut venir
dessiner dans la limite de ces cas pas
de vous proposer l'apple pencil de
première génération et cet ipad là on ne
va pas sur l'écran qui extrêmement
élaboré néanmoins ce qui est quand même
très rassurant derrière c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de performances grâce à la puce
à 12 bionique
on va donc pouvoir faire également de la
prise de notes pour les étudiants
pourquoi pas pour de la bureautique
familiale avec tous les logiciels que
vous allez pouvoir retrouver dans
l'énorme catalogue d'apple l'app store
il est aussi pas mal du tout pour le
divertissement l'écran est très bien
calibrée donc pour regarder des films
des séries
c'est très très bien pour venir jouer à
des jeux vous n'aura absolument aucun
problème mais on reste vraiment dans un
usage familial on ne va pas chercher
d'usagé trop complexe et on peut venir
augmenter l'expérience grâce au clavier
que vous pouvez venir acheter
en supplément c'est lui là c'est le
smart qui bordent de base il est fermé
vous prenez votre ipad vous mettez les
connecteurs juste en face il vient le
protéger sur la face avant est
uniquement sur la face avant pas du tout
sur la face arrière
vous pouvez ensuite venir roseraie
c'est votre ipad pour l'utiliser en mode
cheval et pour ça il vous faut l'ouvrir
vous passez tout à l'arrière vous faites
un ptit pliage et là ça vous permet
d'avoir votre ipad en mode chevalet pour
regarder vos films vos séries et la
troisième partie et bien vous avez
besoin d'un clavier pour venir
travailler
vous prenez vous ouvrez tous comme ça
vous allait ramener votre ipad
à l'avant il trouve sa position très
facilement et là vous pouvez venir taper
un petit coucou extrêmement facilement
bompard contrôlé sur un accessoire qui
coûte 179 euros je le sais il faut être
plus c'est un certain budget vous pouvez
trouver un produit un peu moins cher
avec le trackpad parce qu'ici vous
n'avez pas de trac pas dit si vous avez
un clavier voilà que vous pouvez pas
venir l'utiliser en mode trackpad vous
allez venir faire un peu le trackpad
directement sur votre ipad mais si vous
voulez un accessoire avec un trackpad et
bien vous avez un très bon accessoire
chez logitech c'est l'étui combo touch
clavier + trackpad qui vous coûtera 199
euros ou 95 donc pour un peu moins cher
vous avez un trackpad après ce n'est pas
un accessoire appup accessoires logitech
mais qui est compatible avec votre ipad
de huitième génération côté autonomie
c'est un ipad que je peux garder pendant
à peu près trois jours sans avoir besoin
de le recharger
je les utilise principalement le soir
apple nous donne une journée
d'utilisation si vous allez utiliser
pour de la prise de notes pour faire de
la bureautique familial pour aller faire
vos comptes pour vous connecter sur
internet à peu près 10 heures d'usagé
pour mon usage à moi je le garde trois
jours avant de le recharger avec son
bloc de charge 20 watts inclus dans la
boîte jeudi inclus dans la boîte parce
que cette année apple a décidé de ne
plus mettre deux blocs de charge dans
ses iphone et dans votre ipad de
huitième génération et bien vous l'avez
encore donc ça c'est plutôt bien qu'en
est il du prix
monsieur grain tout noté sur son papier
belgique forcément eh bien écoutez comme
je vous le disais sur la version de base
en 32 gigas de stockage il est à 389
euros
389 euros se permet d'avoir un ipad en
dessous des 400 euros ce qui est très
bien mais ce qui n'est pas bien c'est
que je ne vous conseille pas une version
32 gigas de stockage que je trouverai un
peu trop petit on peut dire oui bien
évidemment vous allez tous connectés
dans le cloud avec un abonnement à une
clause qui peut être pratique mais
j'aime bien quand y en avoir un petit
peu ici j'aurais aimé une fois de plus
une version 64 gigas de stockage c'est
un peu dommage ça apple c'est pour moi
un des bémols
et si vous voulez la version avec 128 go
de stockage bien vous coûtera 489 euros
c'est à dire 100 euros de plus
on y re augmenterez votre stockage et vu
le tarif de base est bien ça fait quand
même une grosse proportion
je trouve ça super de pouvoir avoir
mosmart qui borde un mec je trouve ça
super de pouvoir avant mon apple peine
si de première génération avec mais une
fois que vous additionnez le tarif de
tous ces produits là eh bien ça coûte un
petit peu cher si je pars c'est ma
passion 32 gigas de stockage que je ne
vous conseille pas vous êtes à 389 en
plus 179 euros pour un clavier plus 99
euros pour votre apple paintsil et grâce
aux points total de 667 euros
ça veut dire que vous avez le combo pour
un peu moins de 700 euros tout de suite
la note n'est plus du tout la même mais
parce qu'il ya toujours un mais avez
vous besoin d'un apple pencil de
première génération
pas nécessairement personnellement moi
je n'utilise pas ce n'est pas du tout et
d'accessoires que je vais utiliser hors
des périodes de test personnellement non
pas trop mon truc
l'idée d'avoir le clavier pourquoi pas
parce que ça le transforme en fête et ça
ça crée un usage c'est extrêmement
intéressant ça vient vraiment le
transformer en petit ordinateur familial
c'est beaucoup plus pratique pour la
prise de notes parce que vous avez tous
sous les doigts ça évite de venir taper
sur votre écran même s'il ya des
champions prise de notes sur ipad l'ipad
en lumens je trouve pas mal je trouve
pas mal pourquoi parce qu'on est sur un
ipad d'entrée de gamme chez apple et
qu'on ne peut pas tout avoir
apple a fait le choix de mettre la
performance au coeur de cette machine ce
qui me va parfaitement bien le fait
d'avoir une caméra de 1,2 mégapixel
arrivant je m'en fiche un petit peu le
fait d'avoir tom shadyac et mais avec un
petit peu old school et bien c'est pas
très grave parce que je suis dans
l'entrée de gamme
si je veux pas ça et bien je vais sur un
ipad est requis pour tout de suite
beaucoup plus cher l'autonomie est somme
toute convenable puisque ce qui est
quand même le plus important celles
utilisées qu'il ne rend pas et que tout
se passe bien là-dessus apple a fait ce
qu'il fallait donc ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
est ce que je peux leur commandait eh
bien oui ça reste toujours une question
budget comme je lé rabâcher 32 go de
stockage
je trouve que c'est un peu limite limite
limite mais ça dépend d'elle évidemment
de vous et de vos usages d'ailleurs dit
moi vous quels sont vos usages est-ce
que vous avez un ipad actuellement est
ce que vous comptez en acheter un
quelles seraient vos usages
quels sont vos usages et est-ce que vous
pensez que 32 gigas de stockage c'est
trop peu ou alors que ça pourrait vous
convenir mark et moi ça en bas en
commentaire et cantal on se retrouve
très rapidement pour continuer à parler
tech et d'apple puisque on va parler du
macbook pro 13 pouces et du mac milliers
avec la nouvelle puce apple est mince
assez cool à très bientôt vous
d'amour et prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]